my name is Fadi and welcome to Dark
Souls 2 so I'm not the kind of person or
not the kind of channel to do things in
half-measures my videos require a lot of
editing and Let's Plays rarely require
much so in this series I'm going to make
it different I'm gonna keep it
fast-paced maybe even introducing a new
theme to every episode you know the
theme of this episode is how to get the
best possible start so I asked you guys
my subscribers to join me in adventuring
through drangleic there's a lot to see
and we're going to be discovering this
entire game one video at a time in 2014
things betwixt the huge part of this
game is curing the curse of undeath our
character travels to this old decrepit
castle but upon arriving he realizes
that it has another side to it and
further on in the cinematic he actually
gets drawn into this vortex and I say
drawn because he's not just drawn by
some need to cure the curse he seems
like he's literally forced into this
hole his pupil explodes in darkness and
his hand starts writhing and this just
indicates to me that he's being drawn in
there anyway as you progress through you
come across these dogs and you know this
is the reason the start of Dark Souls 2
really appeals to me and it's probably
my masochistic side saying this but if
you wait in this section too long these
dogs start to surround you and if you
provoke them like I've done then they'll
chase you down and make you become a bit
more wary of the fact that you're
wearing rags and that you have like no
health they chase you towards this warm
light and that's where we're gonna go
next
I actually spy this item off near this
tree this is something you should pick
up because we'll find its use later in
the tutorial in regards to this
cinematic you can skip it if you like
but I have overlaid a lot of gameplay so
it's more interesting
what seems to be the ruckus oh my your
face the face of the curse
it's an undead an undead has come to
play well up here all the ones like you
you spoke to that kind of deer didn't
you you're finished you'll go hallo yes
you'll become one of them hollows prey
upon them feast upon their souls this is
the fate of the cursed so we're not the
only ones who were drawn here let's find
out a bit more about where we are this
is a limbo a link between drunk leg and
the outer world fair traveler I know
that you must have a story why else
would he visit such a place this lost
decayed Kingdom
my name is Milly Beth the old women were
once fire keepers I am here to look
after them it is what my mother did and
her mother before her and so on but now
the fire shows signs of fading and the
Kingdom
is beset by hollows the old way meanest
sisters I am told there was a fourth
long ago fire keepers were commonplace
but now they are lost scattered to the
winds so after being made fun of for a
little while by all these old women
we're gonna head back outside into the
tutorial area if you were watching
during that during that cinematic then
you would have seen me go through this
hole in the bushes that's just before
that bridge and this guy's this is the
reason we picked a sorcerer so we could
take out this guy and as soon as you see
these big enemies at the start of the
game I'm sure you're all thinking you
know if I kill that now I bet I get an
awesome item and you do get a pretty
cool item from this guy is the only ogre
in this level that will give you an item
the item is called the stone ring and
what it does is every time you hit an
enemy it decreases their poise a lot
more than if you didn't have the ring on
so basically you'll break their poise
more often when you smash them and I
think that's really good for weapons
that attack quickly although I'm not
sure so now he's gone we're gonna take
his item further on is some gold pine
resin and then we're gonna continue with
the actual tutorial which I won't show
much of because it's not that
interesting you must go on a journey
without rest well I suppose if you find
yourself at an armed pass but if your
will is yet I'm broken then you may
return here to start again with a clean
slate
so the journey begins let this bonfire
and over to the right is a wagon behind
the wagon is a torch and I think I
should mention how the torch mechanic
works in this game every torch
contributes 5 minutes of lit time
towards your counter you can light the
torch at the bonfire by toggling with
triangle or whatever button that is on
Xbox and you can light the torch right
now I'm like you know there's so many
torches in this tutorial I'm going to
light every single run of them I am
going to see if something happens and
one of our characters is currently doing
that our other character is going to
check out this coffin so we'll go back
to the character who's lighting the
torches but for now let's see what this
coffin is it's surrounded by these ogres
surely if you get it and something
happens right I just want you guys if
you haven't played this game yet if you
haven't got in the coffin try tell me
what you noticed changes something
changes I'm not going to tell you first
time I found this coffin it was like in
previous versions of the game it
actually floated away and you're just
like okay am I going to another area but
then no you appear in the same area and
as soon as you get out you're attacked
by these two guys immediately you don't
get a chance to think and I think that
was intentional they know you couldn't
kill them so they wanted you run to it
and get in and try to figure out what's
changed it took me like I got halfway
through my game before I realized what
changed and I want to know if you guys
figured it out go through the tutorial
and you find a nest and I think you know
what's coming drop the smooth silky
stone we found earlier in the level or
drop the petrified something that you
started with and you'll get a reward so
snuggly The Crow is back and it looks
like she has a friend anyway back to our
cleric who is currently lighting torches
you get to the end and nothing happens
don't light the torches it's a waste of
time so let's finish this tutorial with
our main character honestly I didn't
need to light a torch for this little
cave section but you know darkness on
YouTube isn't a great thing and any
excuse to use a torch I just jump at in
this game I love the way the shadows
look in the way the lighting looks is
just incredible especially at the start
of the game
so you come out into Missoula your eyes
take a second to adjust the harsh light
and this is the hub area that you're
going to be traveling back to there are
a bunch of important NPC's in Missoula
and coming back after a boss to spend
your souls and rest as a huge theme who
are you oh it doesn't matter just help
me open this door I packed my tools in
here seeing it was vacant but now
somebody's gotten locked at all and
that's Lenna grassed the blacksmith who
can't fit through the giant open window
we're going to find the key for his
house a little bit later in the
walkthrough but for now we're going to
talk to the woman who is probably the
most important character in majula are
you the next modern or merely a pawn of
fate
bearer of the curse I will remain by
your side till this frail hope shatters
take this with you may it easier journey
go on and see the king he who made rang
like what it once was he appeared at the
essence of the soul King vendrick
bearer of the curse seek misery for
misery will lead you to greater stronger
Souls you will never meet the king with
a soul so frail and palette seek those
whose names are unutterable the four
endowed with immense souls their souls
will serve as beacons once you have
found them return here to me so that
hope will not fade away so that hope
will not fade away god I love that
dialogue I especially love the bids
where she talks about finding the king I
really like when games set up the fact
that you're going to be this incredible
character later on you start off small
but later in the game you know you're
going to take out someone who is a huge
problem or someone who is hugely
powerful compared to you so now we're
going to adventure through the forest of
the fallen Giants and that name and this
area is interesting from a law
perspective long ago there was a battle
a war with the Giants and whenever a
giant fell in battle a tree would grow
from its point of death and that's
essentially what this entire forest is
made of so you can get some sort of idea
the scale of the battle that must have
taken place and when I played through
this for the first time and even now I
thought god damn that's great game
design you come up from the ladder and
you see this Vista and immediately
there's so much to take in there's four
enemies wandering around that you're
going to have to take out there's this
Archer of the top shooting at you and
there's this little crest
all the night sitting at the tree you
don't know is he hostile is he going to
attack me soon enough you figure out no
he's not going to attack you in previous
versions of the game though he used to
be very aggressive in previous versions
of the game you actually had to skirt
around the outside of the arena in case
you got too close to him because if you
got too close he would attack you but in
this version of the game we're going to
run up this side passage and we're going
to take out the archer and then we're
going to fight the hired knight and the
hide knight drops really really good
straight sword it's imbued with
lightning does a good amount of damage
has an all right move set personally I
like a long sword that we're going to
find in a few minutes
a little bit better so killing him is
fairly optional but you know if you feel
like fighting him go for it he's
definitely not an easy fight and we'll
go through the fight a little bit in
detail in about a minute but right now
let's take out this Archer just take him
up I'm good at this game I promise
see he's oh I almost fell off but I
didn't I'm so good so this character
isn't going to kill the hide Knight
we're going to actually get a fire
longsword later in the level so this
character is gonna make this jump get
this item and I'll show you how to kill
the hide Knight my hot tips for this guy
revolve around one thing learn his
moveset as soon as he finishes his moves
attack him once and you'll just have
enough time to roll away before his next
one connects with you he does have a few
moves that will surprise you but those
are surprises and this is Dark Souls and
I'm not going to spoil them for you what
is this a walkthrough so let's grab his
sword and continue with the walkthrough
so we continue along up these stairs and
we take out a group of enemies and a
common trend I've found in Dark Souls 2
is to take out melee enemies while
having a ranged enemy attacking you in
some way and make sure you be careful of
those fire bombs they do a fair bit of
damage so after this we're going to
climb this ladder we're going to go
inside and we're going to light a
bonfire finally one thing to mention
about lighting bonfires this time around
is that the act of lighting a bonfire
triggers it as a checkpoint which means
you no longer have to rest there and
respawn enemies to trigger it as a
checkpoint
this is Malinche she sells a bunch of
great consumable items five human
effigies ten radiant life gems throwing
knives which are wonderful this time
around and most importantly
the blacksmith's key which you're going
to need but once we've got the
blacksmith unlocked we need something to
upgrade so we're going to get what is
probably my favorite starting weapon the
fire longsword and it's in an
interesting location so once you've
dropped down that ledge it's a matter of
doing some minor platforming to make it
down to the bottom while taking out
these hollow soldiers on the way
interesting thing about these hollow
soldiers they were once part of the war
against the Giants but they've all
hollowed now you can just see that
they're destined to wander around here
aimlessly until they see someone Souls
to take so this this is a cave that
turns away a lot of new players at this
point you might have been playing for a
while or you don't exactly feel like
dying and when you see this cave full of
fire you're like will that burn me when
I go in and then you go in a bit further
and there's this thing shooting
fireballs at you and you're like I'm not
going in there but it rewards the
courageous player it rewards the person
who's looking to take a risks grab this
tentatively and run back and you might
be able to spy this door to the left
open it quickly in between bursts maybe
better than I did and you might be lucky
enough to roll inside this is the fire
longsword and it's probably my favorite
weapon so far if you don't feel like
using the fire longsword for whatever
reason there are a lot of options you
can actually get from the blacksmith so
head back to module arrest spend your
souls and then we'll head deeper into
this castle we've seen some ambushes in
previous levels but it's nothing
compared to what you're gonna see here I
think one good rule of thumb for this
level is if an enemy looks dead it's not
dead and it's going to try and kill you
later in the level so make sure you get
the first hit in like I am eventually
we're going to make it to a fog gate and
this is where you make a choice because
this is where the path branches over to
the right we see this decrepit housing
further down lower by the wall on the
wall on the ramparts we see a bunch of
enemies that are actually quite tricky
to take out especially as you get
further on you'll see what I mean the M
up that ladder is def let's not go there
right now right now we're going to see
these barrels at the far end near a wall
if you see black barrels near a wall I
think you know what to do to them I'm
gonna show you what to do to them this
is what you do to them
after you've been blown up by 10 barrels
of gunpowder just walk it off you know
go through this hole in the wall you
created and you'll realize you created a
shortcut at this point in the game if
you climb this ladder
I hope you've spent all your souls
because you're most likely going to die
of this ladder is one of the only bosses
that comes to you and he only comes to
you once so you get one chance to take
him out here if you don't take him out
here you can fight him later in the
level in a designated area if you fight
him early do you get something special
for it well let's see this is the
pursuer the pursuer who hunts down the
bearer of the sign will not rest until
his target is slain the pursuer hunts
down those branded by the curse as if
each undead soul that he claims will
atone one of his sins I love the concept
of this boss that feeling you get when
you see him fly towards you on that
eagle and realizing I'm halfway through
the level that I have to fight a boss
now then if you have the courage to
fight him you can get your ass kicked or
you can jump off the ledge and run away
completely there are two options open to
you I decided to take him on and
needless to say I regretted it I
regretted it a lot but my curiosity had
to be satisfied so I came back on
another character I have 30 soul arrows
and I know his moveset so I'm gonna try
and take him on the one thing about this
boss that makes him easy is that he has
a very limited move set and he tells his
moves really obviously that stab attack
will curse you if you get too close but
like I said you can see it coming a mile
away and this is the attack right there
that's the one you hit him after he'll
raise his shield and he'll - you just
like that roll out of the way it's your
only option and then a counter attack
once you might be able to get two hits
and that wants to be safe I only had 30
soul arrow and a dagger for this fight
and luckily you just have enough soul
arrow to take him out don't waste any on
the way here use 30 and with a sorcerer
you'll be able to take him out for
killing the pursuer we get a ring of
blades which increases physical damage
and we get his souls if you don't kill
him here you are
the chance of killing him later but do
you get anything extra for killing him
early no unfortunately you don't back on
our main character we decide to go a
different way this is the route we
traveled up earlier and on the right you
see all the decrepit housing we're gonna
make this jump I'm going to take out
some enemies here and we're eventually
going to make it to this cave once you
get in just keep running straight
through nothing's going to kill you
up this hill we'll meet Cael who's a
great example of why talking to NPCs
will give you some great rewards he's
also one of those few characters who's
nice to you even though his mind has
been decayed by the curse oh I'm sorry I
was just daydreaming I think my name is
Cael
I'm a traveler like yourself I'm
navigating the continent to create a man
have you seen majula well there's a
rather spacious manchu there I've made
it my temporary home inside the mansion
I found a strange map like none I'd ever
seen I believe that it's a map of
Tremlett
now I'm travelling the land to prove it
yes yes that's it that's why I came to
the kingdom right no that wasn't it then
what I don't seem to recall in the next
episode we travel to this crumbling city
filled with these ancient Giants this
one the second one you fight gave me
sublime bone dust which you can burn in
the medulla bonfire to make your Estus
flask stronger I recommend going here
early another great item is available
further on which stops you from losing
so much health once your hollowed this
is found just before the Cathedral of
blew the drawbridge of which can be
lowered if you take out the Giants and
once we go up there we'll find an old
friend waiting inside
click the bonfire to figure out what
kindling the channel will do this is a
campaign I'm going to launch soon and
it's going to bring some amazing results
I actually can't wait to read the
comments about Dark Souls 2 so if you
have an experience that you want to
share or something you've found or
something that you just want to talk
about then please post below preferably
keep it about what we discussed in this
episode to avoid spoilers for other
people but generally I think you guys
expect spoilers at this point so yeah
let me know I'll catch you guys next
time so there are some new mechanics in
Dark Souls 2 that I feel like you guys
need to know about these are things that
aren't explained in game and whether
you're new to the soul series or not